good afternoon
as the war in ukraine rages on and
ukrainians fight bravely for their
country
european union steps up once more its
support for ukraine and the sanctions
against the aggression aggressor that is
putin's russia
for the first time ever the european
union will finance the purchase and
delivery of weapons and other equipment
to a country that is under attack
this is a watershed moment
hiv p burrell
will present to you the proposal in a
few
at the minutes time we're strengthening
once more our sanctions
against the kremlin and its collaborator
lukashenka's regime
first we are shutting down the eu
airspace for russians
we're proposing a prohibition on all
russian-owned russian registered and
russian-controlled aircraft
these aircraft will no more be able to
land in take off or overfly the
territory of the european union
this will apply to any plane
uncharted or otherwise controlled by a
russian legal or natural person
so let me be very clear
our airspace will be closed to every
russian plane
and that includes the private jets of
oligarchs too
second
in another unprecedented step
we will ban in the european union
the kremlin's media machine
the state owned russia today and sputnik
as well as their subsidiaries
will no longer be able to spread their
lives to justify putin's war
and to saw division in our union
so we are developing tools
to ban that toxic and harmful
disinformation in europe
and third
we will target the other aggressor of
this war lukashenka's regime
lukashenko's regime is complicit in the
vicious attack
against ukraine
so we will hit lukashenka's regime with
a new package of sanctions
we will introduce restrictive measures
against their most important sectors
this will stop their exports of products
from mineral fuels to tobacco
wood and timber cement iron and steel
we will also extend to belarus the
export restrictions we introduced on
dual use goods for russia
this will also avoid any risk of
circumvention
of our measures against russia
and in addition we will sanctions those
belarusians
helping the russian war effort
all these measures come on top of the
strong package that i presented to you
last night
agreed by our international partners
under this package
important russian banks will be excluded
from the swift system
we will also ban the transactions of
russia's central bank and freeze all its
assets
to prevent it from financing putin's war
and we will target the assets of russian
oligarchs
we continue to coordinate closely with
partners around the globe
and we remain in close contact with our
ukrainian friends
president zelensky's leadership and his
bravery
and the resilience of the ukrainian
people
are outstanding and impressive
they are an inspiration for all of us
we welcome with open arms those
ukrainians who have to flee from putin's
bombs
and i'm proud of the warm welcome
that europeans have given them
we're mobilizing every effort and every
euro to support our eastern member
states
to host and take care of these refugees
we will do this in full solidarity
and with this
i invite hiv people
to give his part
thank you president
as you have said
we are currently witnessing a
fully-fledged war
directly in our borders
the war is again on the borders of
europe
president putin is trampling the
statehood and identity of a submarine
ukraine and its people
what we see is blatant violations of
international law
and with more and more civilian
infrastructure being targeted
international humanitarian law puttings
bombing launching missiles
strikes killing innocent people
but ukrainian armed forces
are fiercely fighting back
and showing a heroic resistance
to this invasion
it's the people on an army
fighting against the invader
but the invader putting
putting wall
is not only against ukraine
we need to understand
the gravity of the situation for us for
the european
for the global security
this afternoon putin has announced
that he is putting russian
nuclear deterrent forces
on high
alert it's important to stress that
the nuclear forces of russia has been
put on high alert
i just had a vtc conference with the g7
foreign ministers and we were joined by
minister koleva
who informed us
of the latest development on the ground
and the ukraine urgent needs
and i told him very clearly
you came last week we asked for
swift and we asked for arms
and now we are delivering on both sides
we are doing everything we can to
support ukraine
we stand by ukrainian people in
practical terms
in one hour
i am convening for the fourth time in
this week
the european union foreign minister's
council
for an extraordinary meeting
and following up the request from mr
coleba
foreign minister of ukraine
i will today propose to use the european
peace facility for two emergency
assistance measures
to finance the supply of lethal material
to the ukrainian army
as well as originally needed fuel
protective equipment and medical
supplies
another taboo has falled
the taboo that the european union was
not providing arms in a war
yes
we are doing
because this war
requires our engagement in order to
support the ukrainian army
because we live on unprecedented times
like you did when the pandemia came
we are facing the best on the wall
as the biblic times
and this will not
finish here
it is the first time in our history that
the european union will provide lesser
equipment to a third country
and i have also instructed my team and
the european union military staff
to set up a mechanism to coordinate the
request of the ukrainian army so that we
can respond in the most effective way
together with the member states to their
needs that minister koleva has explained
us today
today we will provide the political
endorsement also
of the european union 27 member states
to the overall package of measures
outlined by president van der lion
that will pave the way for the swift
adoption of all necessary acts
as george explained
by madam president
we will discuss with the foreign
minister's announcement of tough
economic sanctions
swift
the central bank
i will also put forward additional
listings against oligarchs
will target the elite of the putin
regime
who benefit financially from the system
we will also reinforce our measures
against belarus
who have been facilitating the russian
assault against ukraine
with these measures
more than half of the central bank
reserve of russia will be blocked
also more and more members of the states
are announcing to close their space to
the russian airlines and aircrafts
and we will set a common approach
together with the ministers
and finally this information because
putin doesn't want also only
to conquer the land
he also wants to conquer the spirits of
the people
through toxic messages so lies
the kremlin and its supporters are
engaged in a massive disinformation
campaign
in ukraine
in our neighborhood
and in the european union itself
and we have been fighting against this
information since 2015
with the east stratcom task force
and the european union this information
platform
which
by the way i invite
all of you to visit
and today we are taking a crucial step
to turn off the tap
for the russians information
manipulation
in europe by banning
russia today
and spundek from broadcasting in the
european union
we are killing this nike on its net
we will also continue working
actively in ukraine and in our
neighborhood
to fight the attempts to destroy reality
and to seek confusion and uncertainty
let me close madame president by
underlying
that we will continue to coordinate with
the ukrainian government and
neighborhood countries
and to do everything that we can to
provide all the necessary support to the
ukrainian people
and to put a stop to this senseless war
thank you